lise payette s'est battu toute sa vie
pour deux idées l'indépendance du québec
et celle des femmes faut que les femmes
participent né dans une famille modeste
à montréal lise payette n'a pas les
moyens d'étudier à l'université et elle
commence très jeune à travailler elle
décroche son premier emploi à la radio
et dans un journal de rouyn noranda
puis avec sa famille elle partira à
paris où ses horizons s'élargissent à
son retour au québec dans les années 60
on la retrouve à la radio de radio
canada
elle anime place aux femmes où elle
amorce son oeuvre d'éducation populaire
mais c'est à la barre de l'émission
appelez moi lise qu'elle deviendra une
star dans les années 70 son humour vif
son ton léger attirant plus de millions
de téléspectateurs chaque soir à 23h
gens de mon pays je souhaite la
bienvenue
grand rendez vous de la fête nationale
des québécois
en 1975 elle organise les festivités de
la saint-jean sur le mont royal des
moments inoubliables pour des dizaines
de milliers de québécois
lise payette un sommet de popularité
l'année suivante elle appelle rené
lévesque elle veut se lancer en
politique pour faire l'indépendance du
québec sein de dorian vous avez la
députée la plus achalandée du québec à
peine élu et les nommés ministres et
devient très influente dans ce
gouvernement péquiste
contre vents et marées elle crée
l'assurance automobile
c'est elle qui fait inscrire la devise
du québec je me souviens sur les plaques
d'immatriculation plus tard que ministre
de la condition féminine
elles aident à créer des centres
d'hébergement pour femmes en difficulté
il paraît que j'ai créé un incident
l'incident dont elle parle et celui d
yvette qui sonnera la fin de sa carrière
politique en pleine campagne du
référendum de 1980 elle laisse entendre
que les québécoises qui veulent voter
pour le non ne sont pas assez autonomes
pour vouloir l'indépendance elle
s'aliène des milliers des lectrices au
conseil des ministres la boudent ces
dossiers n'avancent pas elle quitte la
politique elle écrira un livre le
pouvoir connaît pas pour parler de son
expérience décevante du pouvoir après
cet épisode lice payet revient en force
à la télévision comme scénariste auteure
et productrice et les cris des
téléromans populaires qui sont pour elle
des véhicules extraordinaire de
changement social
elle se sert de l'argent qui lui
rapporte pour produire des documentaires
qui dérangent comme disparaître sur la
survivance du peuple québécois
nous ne faisons plus d'enfants
en tout cas pas assez pour renouveler la
population lise payette restera dans nos
mémoires comme une femme de tête et de
guerre une politicienne qui s'était
donnée la mission d'ouvrir l'avouera et
je me suis dit que le moment était venu
peut-être de faire le saut en politique
pour ouvrir des portes je suis bonne
pour ça j'ouvre les portes et je
m'assure quand elles sont ouvertes qu'on
ne puisse plus les refermer jamais ici
se lever et miley radio canada montréal